so you uh you met black in the parking
lot at Edge would you say random Museum
like right across the street from
department store all right food
department stuff who would you say uh
would be your like two or three
influences as an MC that you could point
to
and life
[__]
why Wayne off top how about something
which what's the best Carter too I like
cartoon yeah I'm about to say caught the
one right behind it Carter three is
amazing but about seven first two just
classic how about something crazy
um
um Andre
official
who else
who else would I say certainly not nas
listen man look bro shout out denies I
need somebody to put me on
the right nine songs to listen to
because like I got a cousin who swears
up and down the knives is the greatest
rapper alive he rap
um we just can't take that away from me
that's definitely better than Lil Wayne
see that's what I don't know man I don't
know if it's a regional thing but you
from Arizona Arizona
bro you're from the West Coast like Doug
like how what
it was like it's a good album but maybe
folks over hype them to me and there's
no disrespect or not I don't know
about so we that's what we talked about
I ain't puke that yet still matter like
beats bits and pieces of each of those
if you ever listen to rewind yeah
I mean little Wayne's never written some
[__] like that bro but he's got more bro
it's more when you say more so more is
not always better I ain't gonna say more
is always better yeah quality over
quantity okay more quality he has a lot
of Misses as well but we ain't got too
much bro
Carter three amazing Carter two wait
wait wait wait wait so we're talking
about 2008 is when the Carter 3 dropped
okay I'm gonna say you got a hell of
[__] wait a minute then 09 is no no wait
oh nines No Ceilings yes 09's in the
first No Ceilings
the card is four can we agree that the
Carter 4 had some singles but was Midas
okay there was a lot of [__] surrounded
it
you weren't bumping the rebirth were you
I actually did a lot of rebirth oh I say
Prom Queen on Fire come on okay I know
I Am Not a Human Being you're bumping
that
how about someone uh right above it I
mean good single good songs yeah he has
some singles on it okay okay
by the way very slept on album Like
Father Like Son shout out to Wayne the
Birdman that's classical army guns oh by
the way I'm saying classic to me because
we just had this whole classic [__]
thing in your boy on the couch is over
there like God this guy's saying a lot
classic to me
personal classic like father like son is
amazing I love life my legs are so soft
if somebody told me it wasn't a classic
I couldn't argue with them type [__]
I just feel like after Carter after No
Ceilings I just feel like the Wayne [__]
kind of just fell off a cliff but
there's so much [__] before that bro I
gotta say from 04 to that period at 09
bro you couldn't go anywhere without
saying well I don't think we've seen
well besides Drake at this point now at
that point of time there was no one who
had a more aggressive run than that I
agree
no one as far as like like length as far
as your length a quantity with the
mixtapes yes very light it was insane
that's like we ain't never seen no [__]
like that and it's put out four albums
in the last three years and two of them
got Grammy nominations you think this
knives Run field I'm just saying it's
not I'm saying he's got errors in his
runs it's not for sure I definitely
respect the longevity of it all because
a lot of folks can't win the Dodge debut
it was like 19. well he was on live from
the barbecue main source and 93 I
believe that's that's when I was born so
he been rapping for as long as I've got
a lot at 94. I could be wrong on the
main source what year it was it might
have been 92. and that's amazing I mean
like I would hope to be rapping 30 years
down the line type [__] I would hope to
still be able to and still have a fan
base my thing is he's been rapping all
that time again out of nowhere him and
hit boy just catch a [__] wave [__]
if I
I just
it ain't for me everybody so I haven't
no one's played me a song where it was
like I feel like I need to Envision I
think you like it was written I'm gonna
check it out everybody leaving like I
told you if I don't [__] with that one
or the uh uh what was the
but oh no no let's not even put those in
the same discussion bro all I was trying
to tell you was that Eminem has put out
an album recently that wasn't dog [__] a
fee so listen the Eminem album music to
be murdered by is a good album it's his
best album in like 12 years now I'm not
putting that in any sort of same
discussion as
It Was Written okay I was just saying
like because we're talking about off the
mic we're talking about our goats and I
was like I'm not sure Eminem could be
considered the greatest of all time with
the amount of shitty music he's released
which is also my argument for Lil Wayne
um
I don't know man this is too much though
sometimes sometimes sometimes a little
Wayne it was too much wasn't it no no I
mean too much in the best possible way
period bro I'm talking about after No
Ceilings it was just a lot of mid he
gave it straight he gave us at that
point it's live and everything else is
in the game and Nikki exactly everybody
say all that other shit's negated at
that point anything post 2009
it was
different so would you give Eminem the
same benefit of the doubt
so I was just he gave us 50. I was
younger when uh Eminem's real run was
going on okay side by side I wasn't as
pretty I wasn't like when Wayne was
doing that [__] how was I was like what
14 right so I was really that was my
entry point to music type [__] was like
that's what I'm really getting into so I
saw that as a child it was like that's
where I want to be like I like that type
[__] Eminem I think I was with
seven seven eight when it was first
going on so I wasn't really that I'm
tapping in like that okay so I don't
know I went outside for that one
fair enough
Drake or win
yeah like today all time all the time I
still might give it a drink Mr Drake
that run has been the same bro that's
why I was saying like before Drake I
don't think we had seen anything like
that post Drake yeah [__] bro we just
talking about this in the car was
listening to some of his music bro it's
been I don't think he's left the chart
since he came in no he had that was 2009
bro it's 23 now bro it is 14 years
straight just the number one guy 14
years
yeah it's it's kind of crazy what's your
favorite Drake album if you read this is
too late this is the best rap album yeah
shout out to Clinton Maryland
bro come on man all right
y'all got like ads on here this is
perfect time for ad to pop up well Drake
owes me fifty thousand dollars so I'm
gonna until he pays me my money oh no we
need details man you can't roll past
that he was there
fifty thousand dollars yeah we made a
bet
we made an NBA bet in 2021
and uh you ain't heard from him since
yeah Ah that's [__] up first time you
ever heard come on right Freddie Gibbs
was there we were sitting at the bar at
the at the uh Harriet
and uh he told me that the warriors were
gonna go further than the suns in the
playoffs and I said put some money on it
he said 50 000. I said all right and
then we went to the finals for that man
bro it's all good man I mean it's like
all day you gotta pay that bad
idea no
I definitely dm'd him and was like hey
man I don't know if you're
I don't know if you remember but you
want me to need it feed the bank shout
out to Drake though he's a nice guy
and I've come to peace with him being
a top seven all-time top eight all-time
it's top five Hendrix above him for sure
so this is interesting I love Kendrick
as well me and my partners be having
arguments about this [__] all the time
like I think they're really negative dog
I feel like they give folks different
things for show but I feel like each one
is just as important as though because
you know we were talking about uh who
has five classic albums and it's
definitely Kanye right but you know
who's right behind them yes Kendrick's
right there I just don't I just feel
like bodies of work I'm just like
Kendrick doesn't miss because if you
think about like to pimp a butterfly
when that [__] first came out a lot of
people hated it because it went above
their heads and their [__] musically
weak-minded [__] they're very shallow
fans but like that album aged so well
it's like such a great album like I like
it a lot more I think it was interesting
like when it first dropped me and my
whole girl uh my best friend stays in
Trinidad so I went overseas with her
type [__] and a lot of the people over
there we were talking about we were
having like debates about Cole Kendrick
drinking all that [__] and he had
recently just dropped to pimple
butterfly and a lot of them didn't
understand it right because a lot of
things that he's talking about it's
really like us-based United States and I
didn't realize like how different the
world view on [__] like that is and that
kind of threw me a little bit I was like
I love the album a little good kid Mad
City Charlotte damn I love all the
[__] actually I'll think about
it section 80 crazy
how about so I ran ADHD up so many times
you know how Apple got the [__] where it
plays the uh song with a first as soon
as you get in the car but that [__]
played so many times with my [__] bro I
never used that one never never I feel
unless you know why because I started
off as an Android guy so I had Spotify
look I got both now and not the same I
have both phones you know what I mean I
finally I would never ever like I'm
keeping my iPhone forever I'll get rid
of the Android at this point I don't
know what I was thinking this whole time
Magna Carta was for you it was because I
was like wait what happens if I already
have an Android do I still get the album
the only thing I don't like about Apple
music is how they try to put their
YouTube album on everybody's [__] bro I
still haven't listened to it but the
YouTube app no YouTube oh you oh yeah
yeah every every album every every
iPhone has the [__] YouTube that was
the same type of [__] where you just buy
an iPhone and it counts as YouTube going
diamond or something hold on hold on so
that [__] automatically counted towards
itself yes oh yeah bro you talk well I
think they got rid of the all those like
yeah so it's going up the merch bundles
and [__] crazy
I mean not a bad idea like hey buy a
hoodie you're gonna buy the hoodie
anyway if you buy the hoodie it comes
with a free album it's great and it
counts towards my shoes and it counts
yeah and it counts man
um so let's talk about this new album
you just dropped this new record whoa
yeah which is fire thank you very much
um you got big Creed on the album yeah
what's on the album Big Creek wish I had
Boogie uh I'm home girl shamba
is it Shelly or Shelby it was Shelly
okay yeah not like the Mustang no
no how about yourself so is he back his
drum yeah
because I was [__] confused yeah I
think you did the rerun because of
insanely talented guys who actually fell
asleep during an interview we did once
all right he was so high he passed out
during our interview it's on YouTube
shout out to drugs I was like
I was like am I trippinger shout out to
Drake can't be offering folks rooms I
didn't offer Insurance
all right yeah shout out to drugs again
drum's a very talented guy though
amazing so drum crit West Side Boogie
yeah
um you familiar with dende
amazing artists I'd like to say he just
had some [__] that go went viral
probably like last week from that
mistake he did like an uprox performance
she was crazy
um
[Music]
as well how about another talented
singer yeah but yeah I think that's it
for you like uh how intentional are you
with like bodies of work because
nowadays everybody's so [__] hung up
on like singles and like just dropping
different Impressions on the algorithm
and not really focused on like
cohesiveness when it comes to their
projects before I answer that I'm out of
tweet I can't remember if I said my
proud of Dave David Fuller's also on
there as well but maze a singer
um but as far as albums I feel like it's
different now like it's a different time
real life albums aren't they don't feel
as important as they used to be I mean I
still take pride and like putting one
together yeah I mean an amazing one
because I feel like you still got folks
who listen to it for that and the folks
who stay with you like your fans for
life listen to bodies of work and it's
like it also almost counts as like a
checkpoint where you are in your life
like a Time Market type [__] with the
folks who don't listen to albums fully
they're just gonna make their own
playlist anyway right they're gonna take
their favorite [__] and put their
[__] together I think that's
what we are but I say he'd be trying to
tell me all the time like
making a classic body of work is
important but at the time period that
we're in now it's more about just
feeding the people in general they'll
make whatever album that they want with
the [__] that you put out right so
that's why you see folks like NBA young
boy who dropped where he dropped like
eight projects last year though she's
insane yeah it's pretty crazy yeah I
think like it's like I think though
whenever we think about like the greats
still today
we always go to their Pro we talk about
their albums still yes but
but I feel like they had a different
type of Grace when they came up that
might be fair because we look at them
that way and like the people the last
greats that we always talk about is like
Kendrick Cole and Drake and the last
three greats right now and I still feel
like they came at a point in time where
we were still in but I think even little
baby like I think people look at my turn
and they're like damn he actually came
out and [__] dropped a body of work
that kind of like separated him from
everybody else everybody else in his but
until he dropped that he didn't have the
like before my turn he was dropping
consistently oh yeah he was on his [__]
so he couldn't afford to not drop until
he dropped a body of work and he already
had all that attention looks like it
made sense yeah and I get it so it's
like especially now for somebody who's
trying to like cut through the noise and
break into it I don't think we have I
mean the the luxury of not dropping who
do you think are the excluding uh the
names we just talked about Cole Kendrick
and Drake who is the let's say the last
five five years who who do you think are
the new goats the new goats hmm I don't
know it's interesting man because I feel
like there are a lot of a lot of things
a lot of parameters and boxes to check
for [__] like that like I feel like we
got a lot of people who are extremely
lyrical but haven't necessarily had the
breakout hit example mainstream a lot of
my favorite lyrical artists right now
about so you can go for G you can go for
Kenny Mason you can go for everything
it's a lot of Hometown people for sure
extremely but I think we're all trying
to get to that next level yo man this
last legit I'll miss amazing
album of the year last year when I did
my best albums I put it above uh I put
it above Kendrick's album last year
I feel like a lot of folks were having
that back and forth debate that [__]
Thomas [__] right about to say uh what's
the Cody blue [__] that's my favorite
son the swing on this one that's my
favorite song uh what was the um
the [__] is it I'm trying to think of
the name of that song which one let's
see is the word crackhead in it crack
silence crack sandwich
fire he's one of the best rappers now I
agree I mean but I think like like I
said a lot of us are trying to get to
that next point it's like I feel like a
lot of the lyrical people now with this
uh jail whether it's asaba where there's
a reason what is any of these guys like
we all have very Niche fan bases but we
all want to be like I feel like a lot of
the people that we look at as
Inspirations is like the Wayans is the
Kendricks and the Drakes and all of that
I feel like they did the same thing that
we're doing but they also had the hits
hits they also had the mainstream [__]
that [__] to pull people in and I think
that's what we're trying to get yeah I
think jid's just missing like that hit I
mean obviously he had that big record
with the Imagine Dragons and like put
them in front of a bunch of new eyes but
I just think like you know that breakout
single yeah it's like his own to me he's
like right dude but I think little
babies like yeah blue baby's amazing
he's I think he's the guy the last five
years he's been around I don't think
nobody's [__] baby bro man he don't
win on to some of our favorite folk song
I wrapped him for sure I feel like he
had rap cold I feel like for sure Drake
for sure
he washed Drake went crazy on that on
the uh mesh right that way
Jesus on that little that what was that
a three pack Drake drops yo a little
baby skated right here everybody liked
it and he's like we've seen him like I
don't think we've ever seen somebody get
so good so fast
because I think like when little baby
first came out
you were like hi
no I liked him too but like I feel like
like he was very limited as like a
Lyricist and like he would openly talk
about how Ghana helped him like become
like with his rapping and [__] but now
I'm like yo this guy's just
impeccable or anything you do every day
you're gonna get good at he was in the
studio non-stop I feel like there's a
couple folks from Atlanta like that
right now though because 21 was the same
way true I like 21.
a little bit yeah I love 21. I'd love
when like him and Metro boom and [__]
it's just crazy Savage mode one and two
Jesus that two nuts two's the one
I agree and like I think 21 Savage like
kind of like found his pocket yeah and
it's like